si je vous disais que les musées sont de
véritables exposition de poison prenez
là je compte par exemple dessus il ya
trois à quatre fois la dose mortelle de
plomb donnent pas très cher de vous si
vous essayez de la manger comment ça se
fait pendant longtemps on a utilisé des
produits naturels pour peindre de la
terre glaise à la préhistoire jusqu'au
chauny pour faire du quart manque du
cramoisi tous les moyens étaient bons
pour trouver la couleur la plus vive
malheureusement les produits naturels
sont loin d'être les plus fiables pour
que les couleurs tiennent sur la toile
l'humanité est allé piocher un peu
partout et souvent dans des produits
particulièrement toxique voire même
radioactifs vous allez voir que
l'histoire de la peinture est plus
sombre qu'on ne le croit la couleur la
plus mortelle de l'histoire de nos jours
on sait que le plomb est dangereux une
fois dans le corps il s'attaque aux
reins aux os et aux systèmes nerveux
suivant la dose ça va de la perte de
mémoire à la mort on appelle ça le
saturnisme mais à une époque on n'en
avait aucune idée on a commencé à faire
de la peinture au plomb dans la rome
antique à l'époque c'était génial
s'assécher plus vite tenez plus
longtemps résister à la moisissure et à
la corrosion on en mettait même dans le
maquillage ce sont les grecs qui l'ont
découvert sous forme de minerai de
carbonate de plomb qu'on était dans des
bocaux avec du vinaigre on récoltait
ensuite une peluche blanche qui se
former après une réaction chimique la
céruse et bien ça non ingéré jamais
comme vincent van gogh qui tenta de se
suicider en mangeant de la peinture ça
n'a même pas marché ça à grade et ses
problèmes de santé et ça devait même pas
être si désagréable que ça le plomb
donnant un goût sucré aux choses de
nombreux autres peintres ont payé très
cher le fait de travailler avec le plomb
michel-ange après avoir peint l'école
d'athènes se plaignait d'avoir des
calculs rénaux francisco goya qui
utilisait parfois ses doigts pour
peindre à la fin de sa vie il souffrait
de constipation cécité vertige et avait
les mains tremblantes le plus triste
c'est encore le brésilien candido
portinari foudroyé d'hémorragie
intestinale savais que c'était le plomb
mais il ne pouvait pas s'empêcher de
peindre avec tellement c'était beau il
mourut huit ans plus tard il faut
comprendre que la peinture au plomb
était presque indispensable sans ça vous
étiez obligés de peindre technique à la
prima en une seule fois ce qui est
extrêmement difficile d'autant plus que
les peintres souvent pauvres utiliser
leurs vieilles toiles pour repeindre par
dessus heureusement au dix neuvième
siècle on a trouvé des alternatives
beaucoup moins toxique oxyde de zinc ou
l'oxydé de titane utilisé comme colorant
alimentaire dans les dentifrices ou les
crèmes solaires malheureusement le plomb
sur encore presque un million de
personnes par an souvent dans les pays
les plus pauvres qui n'ont pas le choix
que l'utiliser car moins coûteux la
couleur qui a tué napoléon si je vous
dis vers automatiquement vous pensez à
la nature aux plantes aux légumes
forcément que la peinture verte doit
être issu de produits naturels non
malheureusement pendant très longtemps
c'était plutôt synonyme de mort dans
l'antiquité on utilisait de la malachite
réduite en poudre ou du cuivre qu'on
faisait fermenter dans le vin c'est
comme ça qu'on tinter les verts les
mosaïques ou les fresques le souci c'est
que le métal c'est cher et ça s'oxyde
avec le temps on retrouve encore ces
pigments dans des manuscrits médiévaux
mais c'est surtout la couleur de
certains toits ou sculptures en cuivre
que vous connaissez forcément on appelle
ça le vert de gris il faudra attendre le
xviiie siècle pour qu'un chimiste
remettent le vert à la mode grâce au
père de schild le public a adoré cette
couleur on en mettait partout peinture
papier peint cire de bougie jouets pour
enfants et colorants alimentaires il y
avait juste un souci c'était de
l'hydrogène aux arts scéniques de
cuivres composé en partie d'arsenic un
poison tellement mortels qu'on utilisait
souvent pour faire la mort aux rats il a
fallu du temps pour faire le lien entre
la mort des personnes fragiles et le
fait qu'ils avaient un papier peint en
vert de chine cette couleur a même
presque déclencher une catastrophe
diplomatique dans les années 50
l'ambassadrice des états-unis en italie
est tombé malade à cause d'un
empoisonnement à l'arsenic la cia
pensais que c'était un coup de l'union
soviétique mais après enquête ils ont
retrouvé plein de pigments à l'arsenic
sur le plafond de sa chambre elle en
respire est continuellement pendant son
sommeil rassurez-vous en 1814 soit à
peine trente ans après la découverte du
vert de chine on trouve une solution le
vert de paris une version améliorée belp
du rap comparable à un verre d'émeraude
tout le monde était conquis petit bémol
c'était de l'acétone d'arts scéniques de
cuivre encore à base d'arsenic comment
c'est possible les chimistes l'ayant
développés n'ont rendu la recette public
que huit ans plus tard on a juste
remplacé un poison pour un autre empire
car outre la dégradation de la peinture
sur les murs il peut y avoir des
réactions chimiques en les mélangeant
avec d'autres peintures produisant des
vapeurs toxiques pire elle réagissait
avec certaines moisissures qui l'a
métaboliser entrée hydrure d'arsenic à
gaz toxiques et cancérigènes napoléon
sur qui on a retrouvé de nombreuses
traces d'arsenic après sa mort a laissé
de gros doutes quant à la possibilité
qu'il avait été empoisonné certains
experts pensent que ces traces viennent
en réalité de la peinture de sa chambre
qu'il aurait respiré pendant des années
aggravant son état de santé c'est pour
cette raison que dans certains car tous
nous obliger vidéo certes un poison sont
représentés par une fiole verte la
couleur la plus radioactives le pigment
orange il a une sacrée histoire dans
l'egypte antique on le faisait à base de
reals gare un minerai composés de soufre
et d'arsenic dans la rome antique au
haut moyen âge c'était leur piment et
c'était pas mieux on peut cependant
faire plus dangereux et ça se passe aux
etats unis regardez moi ce magnifique
sets de table avec cette orange brillant
et éclatant conseil ni manger pas car le
pigment orange est obtenu avec
l'occident d'uranium on a même colorier
les flèches d horloge avec de la
peinture au radium ceci afin de les
faire prier dans le noir aucune
protection on lèche les pinceaux pour
affiner les brosses on s'en mettait
comme dernier sur les ongles un dentiste
a donné là l'air quand il a vu les dents
de ses ouvriers tomber des morceau de
mâchoire se détacher certaines femmes
rétrécissait à cause de la fonte de leur
zone cette peinture a condamné plus de
4000 femmes à une longue et douloureuse
mort ce sont des radios girl dont on ne
vit pas dans cette vidéo sur la
radioactivité heureusement avec la
guerre les gouvernements confisqué tout
l'uranium afin de fabriquer la bombe
souvent indirectement des milliers de
vies après la fin de la guerre le monde
prend conscience du danger nord je
rigole on a continué à utiliser des
peintures à l'uranium jusqu'à dans les
années 70 quelle que soit la couleur la
peinture est un poison
si ces couleurs sont si dangereuse
pourquoi ne pas simplement mélangé
celles qui ne sont pas pour faire du
verre il suffit de mélanger du jaune du
bleu non ça nous évitera d'aller
chercher des minerais toxiques pour rien
sauf qu'en fait les couleurs primaires
rouge bleu jaune ne sont pas moins
dangereuse et le pire c'est que c'est
encore le cas aujourd'hui non c'est pas
comme dans minecraft on ne peut pas
prendre du lapis lazuli pour faire du
bleu si ça se faisait un peu à la
renaissance léonard de vinci en utiliser
par exemple ça restait une pierre
précieuse donc très cher c'est au xviiie
siècle qu'un chimiste français
découvrent le bleu de cobalt a beau et
bon marché comme son nom l'indiqué il ya
du cobalt de dans un élément toxique
cancérigène
de nos jours on a une version moins
toxiques le bleu de i want it un mélange
de calcium d'aluminé oxyde de titane et
2 cobalt oui il y en a toujours mais dix
fois moins qu'avant d'un autre côté on a
aussi des bleus bon marché pour la santé
comme le bleu de prusse à base de fer de
carbone et la zot qui est un beau
pigments mais aussi un composé chimique
utile contre les empoisonnements métaux
lourds petit bémol à 252 gris ils se
dégradent et produit du cyanure dans
l'atmosphère coup du rouge c'est pas
joli non plus on a souvent utilisé du
mercure par exemple dans le vermillon
dupont et le jaune au départ c'était fed
à partir d'arsenic de soufre noro
toxiques et cancérigènes en vieillissant
le soufre cesser par de l'arsenic et se
transforme en dioxyde de soufre toxique
et corrosif et l'arsenic devient du
trioxyde d'arsenic pas mieux puis vint
le jeune de naples encore un pigment à
base de plomb plus tard on a aussi le
jeûne de chrome encore une peinture au
plomb utilisé par van gogh ou de
nombreux impressionniste mais celui qui
a bluffé tout le monde c'est claude
monet avec ce tableau regardez ces
nuances de rouge et de jaune sans secret
le cadmium une touche de cet élément
permet de rendre les couleurs vivantes
en plus ça protège votre oeuvre du
soleil mais c'est aussi mortelle
toxiques cancérigènes mutagènes en
absorber provoque des changements dans
la croissance des cellules et des grades
aux organes aujourd'hui son utilisation
illimitée nous on en retrouve encore
dans le commerce bon comment fait-on
pour éviter tous ces produits toxiques
depuis le temps on les connaît par
exemple la peinture blanche qu'on
utilise sur 90% des maisons elle est
sans danger non tout le monde utilise
pas vraiment dans les peintures ya pas
que les pigments il ya aussi des
solvants des rides et de la pétrochimie
comme le glycérol qui permet une très
bonne tenue de la peinture est une
facilité d'entretien ça rassure vos
outils va du coup utiliser du white
spirit pour tous retirés là encore un
produit sacrément dangereux au contact
de la peau et les solvants ça dégage des
gaz polluants pendant plusieurs mois
respirer ça à fond vous allez finir avec
le foie les reins et les poumons en
miettes voire au mieux développer des
allergies certains d'entre vous vont
dire que j'exagère qu'on utilise de plus
en plus de la peinture acrylique à l'eau
moins dangereuses pour la santé elle n'a
pas d'odeur se nettoie à l'eau et
durable et sèche rapidement mais c'est
pas si simple déjà moins dangereux ne
veut pas dire inoffensif pour faire en
sorte que la peinture tienne on ajoute
des additifs des agents de conservation
épaississant la liste est longue et bien
certains sont aussi des produits
toxiques cancérigènes et allergènes du
coup quoi faut arrêter la peinture nom
de nos jours on est bien plus
sensibilisés avec les progrès de la
chimie on trouve de nouvelles façons de
faire avec des matières renouvelables
comme la craie ou l'argile qui évite
l'utilisation de solvants pour éviter
les moisissures on peut utiliser de la
peinture à la chaux avec son ph élevé
c'est ce qu'on retrouve dans de
nombreuses peintures bio les
scientifiques sont même arrivés à
obtenir du bleu durable et non toxique à
partir de la betterave le c'est moins
beau ça dure moins longtemps mais notre
santé vous bien ça
[Musique]